we're deep into the summer season and
i'll ask you what the most hyped
non-sequel of the season is well
whatever your answer is i'd say that a
sizable portion of the fanbase thinks
that god of high school is all the rage
these days which leads me to the topic
of today's list with the god of high
school giving us treat after treating
its fights
why not resume the tradition of listing
10 hand-to-hand fights in anime we're on
our fourth volume for this now but the
train looks to be nowhere near stopping
i've been talking for too long now so
let's kick the whole thing off and let
the anime characters fist do the talking
and hyping
now this is what you call a brawl coming
from an ova of one of the more niche
titles of 2013 is this
fight the two combatants rukaku and
shido roll
tumble and brawl their way into a
spectacle i love it when the fight
becomes as dynamic as this and you can
feel and follow along with the action as
opposed to the typical messy cuts that
characterize some fights of this speed
and intensity
is this one of the most intense
animation that you've ever seen in an
anime fight
i wouldn't be shocked in the slightest
if you said yes the way the characters
move and how much power each blow has
behind it i just i wasn't sure how to
describe that when i first saw it it
sure also helps that the sound directing
as many have noticed in this sequence
is just on point
for such a high tension sci-fi thriller
like ghost in the shell
it's really fitting to have a fight like
this cap off its movie ghost in the
shell arise
what starts off as a shootout quickly
turns into an exchange where the two
fighters trade blow for blow as they
tussle all across the corridor despite
lacking an advantage in the size
department
motoko still takes the fight to rhizo
and gets the better of him despite
losing an arm in the process and
literally
getting her back against the wall
modoko's wits allow her to get away with
the decisive victory and it's a great
way to end a movie that already has its
fair share of notable moments and
sequences
[Music]
while i personally enjoyed uq holder
enough i won't say that it's the best
adaptation out there it's not even close
nonetheless it still has its cool
moments every now and then
and one of those moments is the fight
between torta and kaito
the two face off and go at each other
with a blazingly fast flurry of punches
at the end of the exchange it seems to
be kaito's victory
with him getting a decisive one by
piercing through dota with one hit
bad news for him is that this is uq
holder where people have wack powers and
overpowered characters are a dime
a dozen for how cool it looked in the
anime this particular fight isn't even
as good as the one in the manga so you
better go ahead and read that
speaking of overpowered characters we
have a battle of insane proportions as
the immortal barn takes on the captain
of the seven deadly sins
when you have a cast full of insanely
strong people with powers like the seven
deadly sins
pitting two top-tier fighters against
each other becomes a spectacle
as well as opening a can of worms in the
ever-present shonen power debates
this battle does show some of the great
examples of animation and fights that
help the seven deadly sins become one of
the hot new
shonen crazes for a while it's got
fast-paced action
and the anime team seem to have quite a
bit of fun with the blood in this fight
it's amazing how far we've come right
just ask anyone who's seen the hilarious
art and animation from the latest season
and you'll know exactly what i mean
yeah this is probably one of the best
seven deadly sins fights there is
period seeing this and then the eskimo
fight back to back
makes me legit sad
[Music]
for a series that's not too focused on
battles the monogatari series has some
of the most memorable fights in anime
perhaps it's because of the nature of
the series that the fight sticks out i
already talked about the fight against
kish shot in a previous video so make
sure to check that one out but for this
list we'll go over
karen and koyomi's battle one look at
garen and i pretty much deduced her to
be a skilled hand-to-hand combatant her
brother
well not so much at least goyomi is good
at taking punishment because asgar and
herself said
any normal person would have died taking
those kicks and blows
sakuga fest in every moment as the fight
spills out to various places and garen
dazzles us with her entire offensive
arsenal
this being perhaps one of the most
intricately animated fights in the
series
without relying too much on splatter and
special effects puts it squarely on this
list
now i really love hand to hand combat in
anime and i'm sure that you do too now
wouldn't it be a shame if you couldn't
get the chance to watch the shows
featuring these awesome and
heart-pumping moments because of some
pesky region locks so i gladly present
to you your best buddy on the internet
and the sponsors of this video
expressvpn expressvpn in my experience
is the best
vpn software that you can get for its
cheap subscription price you get some
top-notch quality service
and the fastest speeds available for any
vpn software in town once you boot the
program up just pick your server and
connect
it really is as simple as that now
movies like your name and spirited away
are just a click away so say goodbye to
those guilt-ridden days where you had to
overcome regional locks through
dubious means let's just put it like
that here let me help you out by giving
you three months free
and all you have to do is click the link
below or just go to expressvpn.com
vinnie tube say goodbye to all those
problems with some quick clicks
and start enjoying the internet to the
fullest
if there's one word that i can use to
describe barkey fights it's
wild wild is the cast of fighters we
have in the show
wild is eugero's hair wild is the
sequence which i lay witness to when i
first saw this fight
eugero probably the series most powerful
character finds himself in a david vs
goliath battle against garco gayo
pitting his sheer power against the
sleek moments of the disheveled man
both combatants channel their powers in
a fight reminiscent of hunter hunter
fights
and for a second there eugero does seem
to be on the ropes
how does yujiro finish the fight good
old ear clap but give gaku gayo some
respect
he may have been in an unwinnable fight
but with his showing
i'm pretty sure that he would have given
anyone a run for his money it just
happens that as luck would have it
he had to go through the strongest
person in the berkey universe
hand-to-hand combat's probably not the
first thing that comes to your mind when
you think of kagashi
that makes his confrontation with gakuzu
all the more epic
i never thought that he had it in him
but karkashi made a believer out of me
that day
team 10 also had a good showing in this
fight but i think the gagashi's physical
battle against one half of the zombie
combo did steal the show
it's certainly not the battle of the
titans featuring people at the absolute
top of the naruto tier list but we still
get to see what high level taijutsu can
look like
almost evenly matched with his opponent
and naruto running would give kakashi
the edge he needs to come out victorious
one of the most badass mental characters
in the whole show
no doubt
real drive's not exactly the most
popular anime out there but boy does he
have some
cool fight sequences it's just as you'd
expect from production ig and it's
quality animation team we have sort of
taken on the android in preparation for
his upcoming battles against hold on we
get some funky music to beat to while
the fighters try to outmaneuver each
other through their combat moves and
dodges it's such an intricate piece of
art and while i'm not sure it's worth
going through the whole of real drive
just for the fight
it is still something to take note of
you can check the video of the fights
out on youtube and you'll be amazed at
how well the thing was done
considering it's a 2000 show i know i
was
[Music]
now chinese anime isn't too popular and
understandably so but i recently watched
the show called fog heal of five
elements and i just can't resist
including this fight in this list
two episodes in and i've already got a
gift in the form of this amazing fight
sequence
never had i thought that seeing a guy go
up against a bird would be so much of a
work of art but
here we are the art and animation are
simply top notch and everything ties in
well with the traditionalist art style
of the show
with all the thick lines and all the two
go at it again much later in the episode
exchanging empowered punches and parries
while flying around the battlefield it's
such a joy to follow
and you can get in the zone so easily
due to how beautifully the whole thing's
being composed and directed
so yeah it looks like the non-japanese
people have been upping their game
recently just one of the many nice
treasures you can see from the not so
commonly visited sectors in the internet
less than a few weeks into its run and
the god of high school has already
captivated hordes of anime fans with the
fights
i mean being a series about a tournament
arc you'd expect some quality battles
coming in
but i didn't think everyone was prepared
for something of this caliber
neither fighter gives an inch in this
battle to determine who moves on and
wins it all in the soul leg of the
preliminaries
jin finds himself overwhelmed by his
opponent's stances
but instead uses it to mount his
comeback the fight then comes down to
the exchange of ultimate techniques
where we see jin win
out an epic way to finish an already
epic tournament
there's no question why god of high
school is probably one of the
if not the hottest non-sequel anime in
this season with a few more episodes to
go
i'm sure that we'll see even more
classic bouts down the line
so how's that for volume 4 of a to hand
fights list
the world of anime's physical bounce is
just so exciting am i right i know i'm
not wrong which of them among them is
your favorite
make sure to tell me so that i have an
even better idea of the stuff that you
like that's going to do it for this one
i hope to see you on the next list and i
can't wait
to see more feedback from you don't
forget to like and share if you enjoyed
the video and hit that notification
button so you never miss
any uploads don't forget to check out
our sponsors of this video
expressvpn bypass all those pesky region
locks and even browse sites not
available in your region
with the ever trustee expressvpn now
i'll see you next time
on vinnie tube
you